hello everybody and welcome back to the
channel I hope you're all doing well I'm
going to try and make my way through
this video pretty easily but it might be
a little bit tough for me because I have
yet again contracted a cold I think I've
been kissing the homies good night a
little bit too much but soon I am
actually going out to uh go ahead and
try and kiss some ladies good night that
being said uh if you've been taking me
under on the jordan5 ladies line uh
through all of 20123 and the beginning
of 2024 you might be a billionaire so uh
yeah with that being being said let's
get into this video and I can stop
talking about anything else all right
ladies and gentlemen so today we are
crawling the web what does that mean
well in practice this is something that
a lot of companies have to do when they
want to gather a large amount of openly
available data whether that's to build a
search index like Google or a large
language model like open AI there are a
variety of reasons that we might want to
process all of the information available
on the internet that being said that
doesn't make it a trivially easy task in
fact it's actually quite hard so let's
go and talk about how we might do this
one example if we're just looking right
here is let's say I start out with
Wikipedia Wikipedia might have a link on
it that leads me over to the New York
Times and the New York Times might have
a link on it that leads me over to my
own only fans that would be tragic let's
hope that never happens so assuming that
we know all of these things we can go
ahead and crawl from sight to site they
should all be linked together right at
least at some point so with this in mind
let's list out some problem
requirements Okay so we've got four here
the first is that we need to be able to
scrape all of the content that is
currently accessible online the second
is that we have to store all of it uh
again this stage is kind of optional
depending on what you're doing right if
you're open AI you're going to be using
this as some sort of training data if
you're Google you're going to be
building a search index I don't really
care as much about that particular step
that is more specific to your own domain
I just care about actually crawling the
web and storing the
contents number three is that we have to
respect website crawling policies so if
you're not aware we have these things
called robots.txt files those are per
host on a website meaning like Wikipedia
has a single robots.txt file and it
basically says if you're a bot crawling
my site here's what you can do here's
what you can't do you don't want to
violate those it's not right number four
is that we want to be able to complete
this process within a week now you might
say a week that's a ton of time well
guess what the web has a ton of data
it's not that easy to just crawl it
we're going to need a lot of computers
probably to get this done so let's
estimate how many computers we might
actually need well for starters if there
are around a billion web pages and I did
Google this though that being said there
might even be sub web pages and this
estimate could be completely off it's
hard to say and let's imagine that each
web page is itself around a megabyte
another number that I Googled so again
could be completely off and if we have
to make a billion requests where each
one is a megabyte that means that
ultimately we're going to have to load
in and store at least a petabyte of data
besides whatever you know in index or
model or anything like that that we end
up building additionally let's say we
have a week to do this that means we
have around 600,000 seconds and if we
have 600,000 seconds it means a billion
requests divided by 600,000 seconds is
about 1,500 requests per second now that
is obviously a lot I would say in my
personal experience just using my own
internet it probably takes me about a
third of a second to load a web page I
think that's semi-reasonable so maybe we
need 500 different threads loading web
pages at a time if we did most modern
CPUs have you know four cores eight
threads if they use hyperthreading so
maybe we need what around 100 servers if
we want to devote a decent amount of CPU
usage to this I think that's a
reasonable enough number and that's what
I'm going to stick with obviously these
numbers are going to be wrong they're
pretty crude estimates but I think this
is how you might go about doing a
capacity estimate for this
problem okay the next thing we're going
to do is actually go over the process of
web crawling because it's not overly
intuitive there is actually a decent
amount that you have to think about here
and and do and so the point here is that
once I go through this list we have to
think about which of these items we can
actually optimize and improve in order
to make this process as fast as possible
so the first thing that we do if we're
one of the threads that's actually going
ahead and doing our web crawling is that
we have some sort of list which I'll dub
for now the two crawl list but we'll
rename this in a little bit so imagine
this is just some list doesn't really
matter what the ordering is I know
there's a URL that I have to crawl I'm
going to pull it from that list the next
thing that we want to do is check have
we already crawled this we don't want to
do duplicate work that's just going to
waste time the next thing that we want
to do is check if crawling it is
compliant with the robots.txt file so if
the robots.txt file says hey don't crawl
this we don't want to crawl it if it
says Hey only crawl this every hour and
we crawled it you know 20 minutes ago we
don't want to do it again so for example
if uh you know I was at like
twitter.com SLA and now I want to crawl
twitter.com SLB but it's it hasn't been
long enough between those two crawls I
have to wait a little bit before I do
that and so we want to do that in a
smart manner another thing is that we
actually have to get the IP address of
the host via DNS something like
twitter.com SLA doesn't actually mean
anything it has to resolv to some IP
address something like da da da da da da
da and we have to get that from
something called a DNS server now a DNS
server is probably not just one server
in reality that itself is a distributed
system but we have to figure out what
the IP address is at the end of the day
and when we do so then we can actually
go ahead and jump over to that server
and fetch its
contents another thing that we have to
do is once we know the IP address like I
said we fetch the contents that is in
and of itself an HTTP request and it is
going to take some time additionally now
once we've loaded the content of that
URL we have to check if we've already
processed identical content from another
URL so this is actually something that's
apparently pretty common on the web is
that two URLs with completely different
domains uh actually go ahead and store
the same physical content on them like
the same exact HTML file and if that's
the case it's going to save us some time
if we don't store it again next we have
to parse the content if we're Google
that means indexing it if we're open AI
that just means you know probably
storing it and then we'll have to you
know iterate over it later when we're
doing training uh again store the
results somewhere that's probably going
to be in either an object store or a
distributed file system and then last
but not least we have to take all of the
URLs that this HTML references and put
them into our two craw list so hopefully
that makes enough sense uh it's not too
hard of a process it's clearly one that
is a bit recursive so let's go over how
we can make this thing as fast as
possible and the way that we're going to
start this is by actually pulling from
our quote unquote two crawl list so the
question is if we have this two craw
list which from now on I'm going to call
the frontier if you are familiar with
graph traversal algorithms the frontier
is is basically the next set of points
that you want to Traverse so again we
have this Frontier of URLs that we want
to Traverse how can we reduce the amount
of time that it takes to fetch a URL
from it well if every single node that
is processing so if this is node 2 and
node one is on the left if the frontier
is stored locally per node that could
make prowling very fast because then we
can basically get a next set of links
and just hold them locally without
having to make any RPC calls so that is
going to be fast however it is also
going to have some downsides so even
though it's going to be faster right
because we avoid an extra Network call
when actually having to go ahead and uh
adding things to the frontier at the
same time it has some big downsides so
the first is going to be there's no load
balancing right if I happen to have a
seed URL on one node that leads to quite
a few more traversals than on another
node the problem there is that they're
not going to do equal amounts of work
and one of them might actually go ahead
and be idle now we never want any of our
nodes to be idle we want want all of
them to be cranking at full capacity
until everything has been crawled
another thing is that we can process
duplicate links so if node one over here
on the left says hey I'm going to
process Twitter next and node two on the
right says hey I'm going to process
Twitter next they're both going to
process Twitter they're both going to
store Twitter we don't actually have to
do that only one of them has to do that
and now we're doing duplicate work and
so if we didn't want to do duplicate
work well how could we avoid that we
could have some sort of centralized
database DB
like how I am I'm down bad and this
centralized database would basically go
ahead and allow us to check whether or
not we've already processed the URL that
being said that is going to take some
time because now we actually have to go
ahead and do a network call to read from
the database and so that can be kind of
slow how can we avoid doing something
like this well what if we actually made
our Frontier distributed right so when
we find a URL we're not necessarily
holding it locally but more importantly
we're actually sending it over to other
nodes so this is going to accomplish a
couple of things for us but the first
and most important is that this way we
can make sure by having a load balancer
in the middle that basically we can make
sure that each node is getting a
relatively equal amount of work so the
load balancer could do something like
round
robin at least naively to make sure that
all of these nodes are going to be
processing similar numbers of
URLs so the next question we have we
started to touch upon before which is
how can we avoid duplicate fetches so if
we see the same URL if we've already
processed it before how can we avoid
processing it again well one solution
that we already discussed is some sort
of centralized database and this works
it's doable but the issue here is that
now all of a sudden every single one of
our nodes is going to have to query that
database and if that database is over
the network that's not so easy to do it
can actually take a decent amount of
time so what if recall that I basically
suggested that we do some round robin
partitioning up here in order to uh
route requests what if we did something
a little bit smarter than that well the
idea is that what we could do here is
actually partition our nodes uh by the
URLs that they're willing to process
right so we are doing a basically
Partition by hash range of potential URL
so if X and Y are URLs they will go to
the same node if they are equal and that
way now what we can do is cach some
local state on every single node saying
here's a list of URLs that I've already
processed and so if they find that an
incoming URL says hey you know
twitter.com A/B is incoming they're
going to say I don't need to process
this I've already done it and so that
way we have this already cache table and
so if we're already sending these URLs
around now we can avoid an extra
networking call by doing this
additionally because hash range should
distribute relatively
equally because it's pretty much random
how hashes work if it's a good hashing
function it should distribute our range
nicely um then this should also keep our
load relatively balanced on each node so
another question is well how can we
actually avoid duplicate content on
different sites so I mentioned a common
phenomenon on the web is that basically
we have duplicate HTML under different
URLs and so the issue here is this is a
little bit less simple right so the
first thing that we have to actually do
is fetch the content first which is
expensive then we have to take a hash of
it so so we have to do some sort of
method that takes a hash or a
fingerprint or anything that uniquely
identifies this content so that we can
quickly check across nodes uh basically
whether we've already seen this piece of
content and the problem with this
approach is that since we've already
basically seen these uh or rather since
we haven't seen these hashes before
sending the URLs around there is no way
for us to effectively smartly partition
our nodes such that uh two different
URLs with the same content are going to
be processed by the the same node right
so if you're thinking about what I'm
saying here we're only we only have uh
the ability to know what the name of the
URL is at the time that we send it to
another node to the frontier and so
since we don't yet know if its content
is going to be this or that or anything
else we can't partition based off of its
content we can't partition based off the
hash of its content unfortunately we
just have to bite the bullet here and
get the hash of uh that content once
we've already fetched it and so the
question is well we're going to have to
have some sort of centralized way or
maybe a decentralized way of actually
checking whether we've seen this hash
before so how can we do it how can we
make this fast because otherwise we're
going to have to be sending a lot of
network requests around and we want to
make those not heinously
slow so this is what I would dub content
hash checking and I will discuss a
couple of different approaches here and
you know you individually can evaluate
which one's the best but I think that
all of these are valid we would have to
do some benchmarking to really tell how
much of a difference they would make so
keep in mind mind that let's imagine we
have something like a 64-bit hash of
every single piece of HTML we have a
billion sites that means that basically
we now have up to 8 gbt of data to store
if we want to store the entire set of
possible hashes and potentially even
less than 8 gbt right because there may
be duplicate hashes and then that you
know data set size would decrease so
considering that 8 GB is actually pretty
small in theory we can store this entire
data set on one node in memory and so
that is actually a pretty practical
solution right if we just had some
reddis instance we could store all of
our hashes there the reason I say redis
is we want to make this thing as fast as
humanly possible and redus using
basically a hashmap is going to allow us
o of one lookups in memory and of course
if we want to make sure that our system
is fall tolerant we can also have a
replica over here uh we can just update
that one asynchronously in the
background um and so as a result if
we're always reading from and writing to
the leader we can maintain strong
consistency of course if the leader go
does go down we may lose some rights on
the replica and as long as basically uh
our processing is item potent right then
it's not a huge deal if our replica is a
little bit behind because so what will
you know process a couple documents two
or three times and uh you know it's not
a huge deal then our replica will be the
leader and we'll be good to go again so
again item potency is important here but
uh we can continue to talk about
different solutions so I would call this
one the centralized solution right
because we've got one database that is
the source of truth it's strongly
consistent we can rely on it and it
should be hopefully pretty fast
depending on how close these nodes are
together if this node is in you know the
us and this node's in India at least one
of them is probably going to have slow
requests over to that Rus instance so if
that were the case what could we
actually do to speed things up this
would be a case where you know our
processing nodes are possibly in
multiple data centers and those data
centers are pretty geographically far
apart so again reading and writing to
one single instance of redus will be
slow for at least a subset of our
processing nodes so another idea would
be to actually use like a decentralized
set crdt on every single node so for
those of you who don't really remember
too much this means a conflict free
replicated data type which effectively
means that we are using some sort of
multier replication we're maintaining a
set on every single node and then in the
background on a separate thread we're
performing an anti-entropy process
whereby all of our are eventually
consistent like if we did nothing to
them they would converge to the same
value but it would take a bit to
actually do so so the point is here you
know because these are eventually going
to converge with one another it is
possible that two nodes might actually
uh process URLs that are different but
have the same content but again if
processing that content is item potent
meaning it doesn't matter if we process
it twice it's just a waste of time then
this isn't a huge deal it's possible
that the occasional duplicate processing
of a document
will actually be better than if we have
to hit a Redd as instance in the middle
of everything every single time and so
what that would look like is imagine we
have node one over here node two over
here their starting state is you know
this guy processes a document that
hashes to one this guy processes
document hashes to two this guy
processes three and four they don't
actually have to know about each other
instantly but eventually what'll happen
is that this this guy will store three
and four this guy will store one and two
and So eventually if those documents
come along that are duplicates hopefully
we can detect that and then not process
them again so again this all kind of
relies on the fact that these operations
are item potent and whether it is
actually tolerable if we do process the
occasional duplicate document if we can
this may actually be a better solution
for you it really depends what
percentage of the time we'll have to be
processing the duplicates and as well
how fast we could reach out to a
potential redus
instance the next thing to actually talk
about is do domain name service or DNS
so as I described earlier DNS basically
is giving us a mapping from a host name
something like Wikipedia to its actual
physical server IP address and so this
is going to say now we can reach out to
the IP address to go ahead and get us
the content that we want so the thing
with DNS in general is that if we're
talking about the entire worldwide web
this is probably going to be too large
to just cach it on all of our nodes it's
not changing a lot uh or rather it's not
changing too much so in some senses in
theory if it was super super small maybe
we could actually cash the whole thing
but in reality it's going to be pretty
big there are a lot of websites out
there so typically this is going to
require a network call and the question
is how can we actually go and make this
faster well one important thing to
remember here is like I mentioned DNS is
going to be on a per host basis if I
want to get an IP address for Wiki
wikipedia.com that's just going to be
one thing which is great maybe it'll be
a few but the point is that uh you know
it is stored those entries of IP
addresses per per
host and so basically previously we said
to ourselves hey if we have you know
twitter.com SLA that's always going to
be processed on node one but what if
instead of doing that we just said
twitter.com
sostar that's going to be processed on
node one now instead of partitioning on
the URL itself what we could actually do
is partition on the host so the question
is what benefit does this actually get
us well the biggest thing is that now
per node where we're doing the
processing we can actually maintain a
cach and again it's possible that all of
these uh entries for DNS are going to be
too big to hold entirely in our cash but
considering the fact that websites tend
to link to themselves it's most likely
going to be the case that you know if I
get
cache on our server could be super
helpful for us we can always just use an
lru algorithm So eventually when we do
run out of space we just get rid of the
least recently used entry and hopefully
that should save us a decent amount of
network requests so now again what I
said is that everything from Facebook
will be on the same node as opposed to
just one specific page on
Facebook the next thing to consider here
is actually going to be the robots.txt
file we mentioned that what this BAS
basically does is tell us what type of
crawling rules that we have to follow to
be compliant with that website and so
again keep in mind that based on our
last slide here we're now basically
partitioning all of our processing nodes
based on their host name and this
actually is going to come in really
handy as well for the robots.txt the
reason being that robots.txt is not per
website page it is also per host right
so again we can do the same thing that
we did with DNS and keep a local cache
of the crawling policy again this is
super useful because websites tend to
link to themselves or rather they tend
to link to other pages with within the
same host and so one example of what a
robots.txt file might tell us is
basically say hey if uh we're on Twitter
right my robots.txt is saying don't
crawl this particular link and so now on
a node I'm right here I see
Twitter I already have this thing cached
right it says don't read
and now guess what I do I don't read
Twitter I move on to the next URL seems
easy enough right a second example would
be hey you can only crawl Twitter once
per minute so let's say on this site I
crawl
twitter.com/worldsdumbest have to wait
for a second rather than just waiting in
a blocking fashion where we wait and
don't do any other work what we should
do is take SLB and put it back on our
Frontier we can always put it towards
the back or we can put it you know
somewhere in the middle but the gist is
ideally somewhere such that we can wait
a little bit of time so effectively the
idea here is that you want to keep each
table uh in memory such that you know
now I have a mapping from a host to the
last time that I crawled that host and
so again what we do is we just put the
message back on our own Frontier and
take the next one now ideally this is
not going to involve a network call if
our Frontier whatever that may be and
our actual processing node itself are
co-located it's possible that they could
be on different servers in which case
that operation gets a little bit more
expensive to throw something back on the
frontier and we would have to discuss
that further but in my ideal World they
don't require a network
call okay the next thing to touch upon
is actually going to be fetching the URL
itself so the question is here well
fetching is pretty simple simple it's an
HTTP request to a certain IP address can
we do anything to speed this up so one
thing I have seen elsewhere just when
researching this topic is that people
will sometimes say oh maybe it's
possible such that you know we can
partition our nodes such that uh like I
have certain nodes in Europe that will
only be accessing European URLs I have
certain nodes in America that are only
going to access American URLs and it
seems that the general consensus on that
is that it probably doesn't work just
because the domain typically doesn't
indicate where the URL is actually
hosting right I might have a European
domain I might have a like a UK uh but
at the end of the day that doesn't
necessarily mean the site is going to be
hosted in the UK so it's unclear we
might get some benefit from doing
something like this but for the most
part we're probably just going to have
to eat the penalty of actually fetching
the
URL okay moving onwards now we have
storing results so like all other things
when we make a right we want to make a
right to somewhere that is physically as
close to our server as possible right
and in this case our rights are going to
be pretty expensive because we're
writing full HTM HML files possibly
indexing those HTML files and doing a
bunch of other different things with
them so of course we do want data
locality wherever we can get it now if
our nodes are running in some sort of
Hadoop cluster it would be great if we
could just export those to hdfs that
would make life super easy that being
said I do find that a lot of people
choose not to run their own Hado
clusters they're tough to manage they're
kind of expensive and so a lot of the
times especially when we just need to
store tons of storage like in this
scenario we're probably going to be
using S3 if we are it would be great if
we can make sure that our servers that
we're doing all of these processes on
are in at least a similar data center
right so if I'm in uh Us East one for my
S3 Zone uh it would probably be really
good if those ec2 instances that I'm
using are also in Us East one it is
going to make the latency of writing
quite a bit lower and it's probably
going to be cheaper than running hdfs of
course this is all going to vary on your
specific use case and uh you you know
you have to try everything out in
Benchmark it but this is at least the
Assumption I'm operating
under okay let us go ahead and talk
about pushing to the frontier the last
aspect of this problem so now we have
basically we've parsed our HTML document
we've maybe got five or 10 or even 20
different URLs that we know we have to
go ahead and search next what should we
do with them well the first question is
how do we actually want to model our
Frontier and I'm thinking about this
question from like a data structures an
algorithm perspective because at the end
of the day what we're effectively doing
here is a graph traversal and if we're
traversing a graph what algorithm do we
want to use in order to Traverse it well
one option is that we can do a depth
verse search right so when I basically
access a website I get the first link
from it I start traversing from there uh
you know all the other links I'll deal
with them later and I just keep going
and going and going uh we could do that
with something like a stack if we were
able to build it uh recursion is kind of
weird and like a distributed setting I
don't know how well that would work um
but the issue here is you know how do we
really build a distributed stack right
if I have this whole block of URLs to
potentially Fetch and then you know I
got one guy adding to it from one
process I got another guy adding to it
from another process and then another
guy adding to it from another process I
don't know I kind of lose the the idea
of what a stack really is because you
know what was once the top of the stack
is is now not being popped it just
doesn't really make much sense to me
personally uh I think what does make a
lot more sense would be a Quee and
performing a breath first search again I
think the breath first search is also a
better option here just because websites
tend to link to themselves and if they
do tend to link to other sites that are
on the same host again our caches are
going to get a lot more hits as opposed
to Misses and that can be really useful
so how can we actually go ahead and
model A que well in a distributed
fashion there are quite a few things
that do this for us what does that
message cues uh the type of message CU
that we're going to use still yet to be
determined we'll discuss that that in a
minute but uh I personally think a q
makes a lot of sense for us here then
the last aspect of this is potentially a
priority Q when I was reading through
some of the literature on how to
actually build a web crawler um I did
see a decent amount of information
saying that certain sites will actually
choose to basically include a quality
factor for every single potential URL
that they're going to crawl and then uh
crawl them in some sort of preferential
order I'm not sure how practical this is
going to be for just like a naive
WebCrawler but I suppose if you really
wanted to you could build some sort of
inmemory Heap and then do something like
that and uh you know put that on a
separate server I don't think we're
going to do it for this video let's keep
things simple enough I think that's
probably a little bit uh out of the
cards for a system design interview but
it is still worth thinking about if it
were
relevant Okay so we've basically said
now that our Frontier is going to be a
bunch of cues so that we can breath
first search all of our links it's going
to allow us to take better advantage of
all of that caching that we're doing on
our processing nodes so the question is
what technologies do we want to choose
well a couple of things as always if we
are building a web crawler we want to
crawl the web reliably we don't want
things to fail and if they do fail we
want them to come back up and restart
from where they were additionally it
would be great if we didn't have to
build all of these solutions for a
partitioning replication load balancing
ourselves it would be great if we could
use some technologies that just went
ahead and did that for us and so for
this reason I am going to continue my
track record of being a Flink sexual and
I'm going to suggest that that we use
both Kafka and Flink so as we know Kafka
is a log based message
broker uh meaning that messages are
persistent on dis so if we go down we
can recover and start reading from the
offset that we were at before and then
Flink of course is going to allow us to
keep local state on that consumer that
is Fault tolerant we can keep that state
in memory it's okay if Flink goes down
because occasionally it's going to be
checkpointing and when it comes up it's
going to bring up the checkpoint that it
was last at it's going to remember the
Kafka offset corresponding to that
checkpoint and then it'll just start
reading messages from Kafka because
they're still on dis in Kafka and so you
can actually just build back up that
state deterministically in our case we
aren't going to have deterministic state
because you know there's still external
systems getting involved uh our DNS
results can be modified from one run of
a Flink thing to another uh but it is
still going to make sure that we do end
up actually you know crawling every
single link that we're trying to crawl
and so another nice thing here is that
you know if we have a Kafka instance we
have a Flink instance well we don't
really want Flink to be having to make a
network request to Kafka all the time or
at least if we do we want it to be as
fast as humanly possible so ideally what
we can do is just collocate these two
either on the same physical server or in
the same Data Center and that way we can
ensure that latency is as low as
possible because if you recall they're
going to be a lot of times where we're
trying to crawl a website and it's
robots.txt is going to say hey you can't
crawl this yet and then then we want to
go hey Flink it's time to rein Q on your
own kfka q and we want to make that as
fast as humanly possible so again like I
mentioned full replayability we know
we're not going to drop any links and of
course uh partitioning is super easy to
do with Kafka it's got zookeeper under
the hood and uh it can just go ahead and
do all of that for us we just have to
provide it with a partitioning key which
as we mentioned is going to be the host
of the URL of course all of the rights
to S3 can be item potent right because
at the end of the day if we take some
HTML content and we set its URL to just
be the hash of it uh then if we write it
again uh we're just going to overwrite
whatever content was previously in S3
there so that's fine this is all good
and well uh we need basically any
external interactions from Flink uh you
know if we're going to another system we
want that to be item potent because of
the fact that we're going to have to
replay things sometimes if our flank
instance goes down and then of course
the really really nice thing about flank
is that we can B basically use all of
that internal State and the ability to
cach things in memory in order to do
caching of both DNS results and
robots.txt results per host which is
going to be super nice for us so let's
go ahead and talk about our final
design for our WebCrawler right here
let's imagine we've got three separate
nodes over at the bottom these guys are
going to be doing all the processing
again I thought it was very important
that both the frontier and the processor
are at least in the same data center but
ideally collocated so effectively we've
got these collocated Kafka q's and flank
instances and they're going to parse a
bunch of URLs and once they do you know
now all of a sudden we're sending our
URLs back to the load balancer the load
balancer is going to say hey wait a
second you know some percentage of these
might go back to you some percentage of
these are going to go to this guy some
percentage of these are going to go to
this guy and then they can just keep
processing and that's all going to be
based on the host name now of course
once we're processing something
if the data isn't cached we're going to
have to pull from our DNS into our flank
instance we are going to have to read
from the redis cache in order to see
whether or not we've processed this HTML
before and then we're also going to have
to write back to the redus instance to
basically say hey I've processed a an
HTML document here's its hash you should
hold on to this thing uh it's going to
have a single replica or you know as
many replicas as your heart uh is
content with and of course we also have
S3 which is ultimately going to be the
sync of all of these operations now I
did mention that we don't necessarily
need to have these reddest things we
could do like a
crdt of all the hashes that is local to
all of these nodes right here but at the
end of the day I do think that redus
keeps things pretty simple of course if
uh our system was too slow we could
always try switching to a crdt
implementation and seeing if that helped
us out at all anyways guys I hope you
guys found this video informative I am
now going to sign off as my throat is
hurting me a little bit I wonder why and
I will see you all in the next
one